كان رايان يبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا ، وكان صبيًا في
الكشافة ، وتلقى ريان نجل الطالب بولين ستيوارت
الرسالة ذات
مساء في شهر فبراير
بعد ساعات ، حيث انتحر رايان مذعور بحياته ،
وتواصل معه شخص ما متظاهرًا
بأنه فتاة وبدأوا محادثة
سرعان ما أصبحت محادثتهم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
حميمة ، فانتحل المجرم الإلكتروني على
أنه فتاة أرسل إلى ريان صورة عارية ،
ثم طلب من أحدهم في المقابل
أنه أرسلها لهم
وطلبوا منه خمسة آلاف دولار
، وأخبرهم أنهم لا يستطيعون ذلك لذا قاموا
بتخفيضها.
المال رايان ، طالب في المدرسة الثانوية ،
وافق على الدفع للمجرمين من
مدخراته في الكلية ، لكن مطالبهم زادت فقط ،
حيث هددوا
بنشرها على أفراد الأسرة
ووضعهم على الإنترنت ، قالت بولين
ليلة سعيدة لابنها في الساعة 10 مساءً
بعد فترة وجيزة من حدوث الأمور المدمرة  بدوره
كان لا يزال طفلًا عاديًا سعيدًا ، ولكن بحلول
الساعة الثانية صباحًا ، كان
هذا هو الوقت الذي قضى فيه على حياته ،
بولين تقول ملاحظة تركت وراءها شددت على
مدى إحراج رايان  بالنسبة له
ولعائلته ، كان
يعتقد حقًا في ذلك الوقت أنه لا توجد
طريقة للتغلب على هذه الصور إذا تم نشر هذه الصور
بالفعل عبر الإنترنت ، أظهرت ملاحظته
أنه كان مرعوبًا تمامًا ولا
ينبغي أن يكون أي طفل
خائفًا إذا سمعت عنه من قبل  هذا النوع من
المخططات يطلق عليه اسم الابتزاز الجنسي وزيادة عدد
الضحايا الآن ، حيث قام مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي بتحذير
الآباء من الساحل إلى الساحل ، حيث
يقول المكتب إن هناك 18 ألف
شكوى متعلقة بالابتزاز الجنسي في عام 2021
بخسائر تزيد عن 13 مليون
دولار ، يقول مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي عن الاستخدام  كما أن
استغلال المجرمين في المواد الإباحية لإغراء
الضحايا يشكل جريمة خطيرة